(spirited music)
- We are currently in the
train from Munich to Vallendar
to attend the forum WHU,
a student-run conference
on business matters.
So I thought I'd do this
a bit in the vlog style.
You can follow me around
and see what we are doing here together
as (indistinct) students of this really,
probably the best private
business school in Germany.
I will share a couple of my insights
of what my student time was like,
what I would recommend you
to make the best out of your
time in business school.
So follow me for the day, very
much looking forward to it.
(spirited music)
We got just picked up in Koblenz
by the team from forum WHU,
and we're on our way to the conference.
I'd argue two of the big advantages
of studying at a school like WHU.
Is that first, you really are in a network
of highly motivated, highly capable,
other business students as well.
This will very likely
help you then later on,
and second, you will also have
lots of access to companies
who go to the career
fairs, present themselves.
This will enable you to
network with the recruiters,
surely a big help.
Of course, to some extent,
this is also the case at public
universities like in Munich,
but certainly less so.
Though, of course, what
I also enjoyed in Munich
that for instance, I did also
second bachelor in philosophy.
So you have the opportunity to also look
into other subject areas, degree areas,
(indistinct), of course,
at a business school,
typically you're more
limited to this one subject
that you are studying there.
(spirited music)
We now arrived here at the conference.
I will give a workshop
in about half an hour.
So the conference is already
ongoing for several days.
Most of the attendants
already now joined one of the sessions.
So we just had some good lunch.
I will fill up here my coffee in a second.
And then we are ready to go
for the workshop of today,
which I will talk about
professional communication
here at WHU in Vallendar.
(spirited music)
(upbeat spirited music)
I do occasionally do lectures
for students like this.
Besides here at WHU,
I'm also a lecturer at the
University of St. Gallen
for the MBA program.
I will do a video about
my experience on that
in the future as well.
But usually I talk about topics
such as professional communication,
slide writing techniques,
and also problem solving skills.
So, typical things that are
part of the consultant toolkit
that I do think many
students will benefit from,
especially those with
a business background
that want to make their way
into professional
services like consulting.
So this was also the focus of today
with some many great
discussions, questions,
participation from the students,
very high energy and engaging environment.
It's a pleasure to be here now
with Vanessa, Patrick,
Hendrik and Marijan,
four master students at
the WHU here in Vallendar.
So I'd love just to hear from all of you
what it's like to study at
such a private business school.
It is indeed, I'd argue,
probably the best business
school in Germany.
So for sure, not your average student,
with whom I'm surrounded here with,
but maybe let me hear from you.
What is special about studying at WHU,
studying at such a private university?
Who wants to start?
Maybe can (indistinct).
- Oh, I can start for sure.
Well, I think it's very special
that we are very close community.
You are so close to your friends,
you meet them every day,
and of course that's very
important for your future work.
You will be connected for
the rest of your life.
I think that's what makes it special.
- Maybe another very interesting aspect
is actually the network, right?
It's amazing which type of
people we have here on campus,
be it as guest lecturers,
or be it as parts of all
these different conferences.
A very memorable moment for me
was when Kagan Sumer, the
CEO of Gorillas, was here
and talked with us and explained
many different insights
from the company.
That was for me, very interesting
to see that such a person
would be at WHU.
- Just for the uninitiated,
Gorillas, at the moment,
probably the fastest-growing
startup in Germany,
who reached, I believe, unicorn valuation
just a couple of months after foundation.
So a pretty insane story indeed.
But I like what you just
said, the memorable moment.
Maybe also to hear from the others.
What was your memorable
moment, most memorable moments
so far in your experience at WHU?
- Oh, I guess for me,
I'm going to take this,
I guess for me it would be
the moment I actually got
accepted into the school.
I mean, WHU, or as we call it, vey-hah-oo,
has very, very high prestige
and naturally it's a great thing
to be admitted in this school
and to be part of the program.
And so for me,
finding out I was actually
going to be part of it
was just the non plus ultra, as we say.
- Yeah, for me,
it was also the first weeks
when we met everyone and got
introduced to our classmates,
and the Career Center,
which I think is very good and
helpful to start our careers
and get connections to companies,
and yeah, other CEOs of great
businesses and industry.
- To just pick this exactly up.
I mean, this is for
sure one of the reasons
why people like to go to
business school like that
because of course they hope
that it will benefit their career.
I mean, obviously.
What does this mean at WHU,
at university like this?
So how does such an university
like here in Vallendar,
how does it help you?
How does the team help you
to get into the career track
into your dream employers
that you want to do?
- Maybe I could pick up on that.
And then I guess one of
the most important factors
that plays into this
is actually the Career
Center that the WHU has.
So we have an in-house Career Center,
which is actually specialized
on making sure that,
or connecting students to actual
companies out in the world,
and guiding us and giving
us some sort of a path,
looking at our CVs, looking
at our cover letters
and basically making sure
that the students have the
best possible opportunities,
that they're out there,
and to really push
themselves in the direction
that they have to go, or want to go.
- Maybe another very interesting thing
are all the career events, right?
So they invite all these
big companies, right?
McKinsey, Bain, they
come on campus, right?
You talk with the consultants.
I mean, in terms of COVID,
of course some things were online,
but still even the Baineys
were here on campus
and really explained us
everything, talked to us.
And this is really, I
think this is very unique
that all these companies
also come to this university,
and that's, I think, very special.
- Thank you for these insights.
Also, I learned something
myself, much appreciated.
Yeah, all the best to all of
you and your future career.
Cheers. Thanks.
- [The Students] Thank you.
So we are done for the session for today
and back on our way to Munich.
I must say I had an amazing
time with all the students.
I always find it so energizing
to talk to these people,
understand what their ambitions are.
And of course to do my
best to hopefully also
teach them something new, as
I did with these sessions.
So, as always, I hope
that you took some value
out of this video as well.
If you did,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all the content.
Of course, if you have any questions,
leave me a comment below
in the comment section.
You'll also find me on other channels,
such as Instagram,
LinkedIn, TikTok, or Twitch.
My name is Heinrich,
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
Big, big thanks also to all
the members of the channel,
you're really supporting and
contributing to the work.
Looking forward to talk
to you again next week,
until then, then all the best to you,
and bye bye.
(spirited music)